il n'aura pas fallu attendre que la loi
sur le renforcement de la laïcité ne
soit adoptée en france pour que l'état
mette le cadenas dans la porte de la
mosquée de pantin en région parisienne
notre lecture de cette fermeture c'est
tout c'est qu'elle est disproportionnée
est vraiment injuste injuste puisque
c'est une mosquée qui a été depuis tout
le temps dans l'accompagnement la
dénonciation du tout ce qui y ait des
actes terroristes
le gouvernement français n'est pas
d'accord en ordonnant la fermeture de la
mosquée pour six mois
ils lui reprochent de favoriser des
sentiments anti républicain qui avait
relayé sur sa page facebook la vidéo du
parent d'élève qui s'en était pris à
l'enseignant décapité samuel pâtit dans
cette vidéo le papa disait que le prof
demandé à ses élèves il dit parmi vous
qui est musulman et celui qui est
musulman il lève le doigt
donc nous on a dit est ce que
l'éducation nationale c'est ça
l'objectif de l'éducation nationale ces
deux destins gay
les élèves les enfants parce que c'est
des adolescents c'est un collège en
fonction de leur religion qui est par
niveau musulmans la décision de
fermeture s'appuie aussi sur les liens
avec le salafisme qu'entretient la
mosquée sur sa fréquentation par les
personnes impliquées dans la mouvance
jihadiste et sur la personnalité trouble
de son imam principal ibrahim doucouré
il a depuis été congédié pour acheter la
paix avec les autorités directeur de la
mosquée ne condamne quang nam
tout ça c'est une chasse aux sorcières
croit thing il ya 76 mosquée qui vont
être fusionnées
mais il ya 700 qui ont la trouille
maintenant toute puissance qui est dit
est peut-être c'est moi peut-être c'est
moi et après on dit oui mais là il ya un
projet de loi qu'est ce qu'on peut vivre
je veux pas parler j'attends que mon
revenu peut-être faire une perquisition
chez moi le projet de loi qui sera
présenté ce mercredi
il veut resserrer le contrôle de l'état
sur la formation et sur la certification
des imams de france et à franchir les
mosquées des influences étrangères
la règle en france dans un état laïc
c'est la religion s'occupe pas de la loi
est la loi elle s'occupe pas de la
religion mais on a des pays étrangers
qui décident de qui va être recteur de
la mosquée de paris par exemple c'est
l'algérie c'est pas cohérent
c'est à dire ce que ce que le
gouvernement français s'interdit il
autorise à d'autres gouvernements pour
sa réserve sur ce le territoire français
slimane kadri et travaillant social à
lille il dit avoir été témoin au fil des
ans d'une insidieuse emprise d'un islam
de plus en plus militants sur certaines
communautés le plus souvent défavorisés
le projet de loi y pour lui essentiel
c'est un vrai problème en france parce
que je pense que la france aurait pu
gérer ces questions là c'est qu'ils sont
la montée de l'islamisme qu'on va
devenir quand même depuis très longtemps
tout à fait autrement qu'elle a souvent
été ou très haut très naïve l'éducation
nationale est l'une des pierres
angulaires du projet de loi qui
souhaitent adopter le gouvernement dès
la rentrée l'an prochain l'école sera
obligatoire à partir de 3 ans plus
question pour des parents d'inscrire
leurs enfants à la maison sauf pour des
impératifs de santé
objectif renforcer le contrôle des
écoles confessionnelles hors contrat et
prévenir les écoles clandestines ou des
enfants se retrouvent endoctrinés et le
plus bas âge
bon on retrouve la propagande islamiste
habituel je parle sur les relations
hommes-femmes
d'abord la cij pour que je bosse en
mettant dont tout le monde voit bien de
quoi il s'agit on peut leur parler de la
charia donc et puis et puis on va aussi
en général développé toute une
tout un discours sur d'autres
religion d'autres croyances sur d'autres
communautés en particulier la communauté
juive par exemple et des discours de
haine
les gens ne choisissent pas d'accord
destiny t ce n'est pas un choix dira
j'aimerais bien qu'un destin non les
gens veulent bien qu'il y ait une école
connu reconnu et tout mais il ya
beaucoup d' entrave
si vous ouvrez une association on parle
pas des cons vous une association pour
l'apprentissage d'une langue chinoise ou
la longue
indien aucun problème or aucun problème
vous l'ouvrez vous faites des
inscriptions vous louez tout vous ouvrez
une école pour l'apprentissage de la
langue arabe tout de suite que les
problèmes que des enquêtes pourquoi vous
cherchez quoi les critiques virulentes
des cris noah islamophobe
les défenseurs les plus ardents de la
laïcité accuse ses détracteurs
d'instrumentaliser l'islamophobie ici
marie ève bédard radio canada paris